[Music]
I thought we were gonna get heard your
mother trampolining
superheroes are illegal you wanna fight
bad guys defines Who I am
we're not saying you have what someone
on TV said I was approached by this
tycoon most to talk about hero stuff
help me bring supers back into the
sunlight
we need Elastigirl
[Music]
kids no problem not the way you're
supposed to do it dad they want us to do
it I don't know that way why would they
change math over Dusseldorf do those are
dogs yeah that's so heavy
atropine closing I couldn't have done
this if you haven't taken over so well
I've got to succeed so she can succeed
done properly parenting is a heroic act
done properly
hey everybody is Charlie we got some new
Incredibles from the Olympics and
because black panther is out this
weekend and i'm gonna be doing a whole
bunch of Marvel related stuff be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos and make
sure you click that Bell to enable
alerts so you don't miss any of the
videos just because it is kind of crazy
with all the Olympics stuff going on and
you can kind of see what they're doing
here they're flipping the script from
the first film and in the way that
syndrome was pretending to support
superheroes sending out mr. incredible
on missions for like that first big
chunk in the movie before you found out
what was really going on
and the entire family got in on the
action they're probably doing the same
thing with Elastigirl but obviously it's
a new villain in like they show you a
little bit more about Jack Jack's powers
and Edna has that line at the end where
she says parenting is a heroic act
it sounds like Jack Jack will be a much
bigger part of them beating the villain
like mr. incredible has to be a good dad
to help Jack Jack be the hero that he
can be albeit with a lot of comedy
thrown in and the rest of the family too
you only get a little bit of the other
kids like they had that new math joke
raise your hand if you're actually old
enough to remember new math now like I'm
not that old but they did make jokes
about it when I was in school like my
math teacher actually explained way back
in the 50s and 60s there was this new
method of doing math that they tried to
introduce to United States schools that
just got completely trashed they threw
it out so after the 1960s you never
heard about it again like everybody
thought that it was ridiculous which is
why mr. incredible is like banging his
fists on the table math is math why
would they change math which is
basically him speaking for the entire
nation that had to sit through that
whole ordeal they have John Ratzenberger
back as the Underminer for that first
little bit of the film the fact that
they're still learning about Jack Jack's
power sort of explains why they wanted
to pick up immediately after the first
film ended it's been so long since that
first movie came out that people are
probably scratching their heads a little
bit
trying to remember so I would recommend
re watching that movie if you haven't
seen it recently before you go see the
second movie so they pick up they defeat
him and then they go back to their lives
and here's where we get into the villain
of things because it's a very familiar
twist that they're probably gonna flip
on its head from the first film with
syndrome pretending to support
superheroes so you probably detected Bob
Odenkirk voice he's playing a character
called Winston Dever he's like this evil
Elon Musk tech billionaire that really
wants to bring superheroes back but in
the way that really rich weird people
are evil in a lot of these films he
probably just wants to find a way to
prop it off of them so this is probably
all a front for something else that's
going on but remember how mr. incredible
was slowly suffocating to death behind a
desk during the first film the same
thing kind of happens to Elastigirl like
she is so excited that people want her
to go be a superhero so she's like
alright great so she just completely
drinks the kool-aid so it'll be
interesting to see if the same thing
happens to her where it takes her a
little while to figure out that someone
is really playing her for the fool like
it took mr. incredible a little while in
the movie to figure out that buddy was
really syndrome so I think that they're
gonna speed that along I don't think
they're gonna do the exact same thing
that they did during the first film but
you find that there are a couple of
characters that are just obsessed with
superheroes
the whole idea is that obsession usually
leads to bad things happening here's
where it gets a little more complicated
though we found out that Catherine
Keener is actually playing the sister of
this Winston character that Bob Odenkirk
is playing and she's just described as a
tech happy problem solver in evidently
the real brains behind the Dever
successful company so big surprise she
actually might wind up being the true
villain of the film if she's the real
brains of this billionaire Empire and
he's just the face of it they may have
flipped that script from the first film
where you have a shadow figure
manipulating the public face then
everybody is actually interacting with
for most of the film because just
reading the description of her character
makes her sound like an evil version of
Edna mode they also added another
character called void played by Sophia
Bush that's obsessed with Elastigirl
but they didn't say whether or not she's
gonna be an evil character so her
character might wind up being a version
of buddy for Elastigirl and then
obviously Frozone is a much bigger part
of the plot like oh I got this company
they want to work with superheroes we're
getting back in the game
whereas my supersuit honey there is
another character that we don't see in
the trailer played by Isabella
Rossellini and she just described as a
foreign dignitary known only as the
Ambassador that's all about the legal
return of supers so she might also be on
Team villain it just sounds like they're
a couple of mysterious things going on
here where you have this tech
billionaire Empire that secretly run by
Catherine Keener character then a
mysterious foreign dignitary that just
suddenly wants superheroes everywhere so
he just sounds like some James Bond
Spectre level stuff is going on here but
looking at his character model here he
has these really vacant looking eyes he
just might be the face of it with people
pulling the strings behind him the
actual movie isn't out till June 15 so
they'll be releasing a whole bunch more
trailers we'll see more of the
characters but let me know what you
think of this so far obviously most of
what you see in this is probably only
the first part of the film like usually
what happens is is that one of the
characters drinks the kool-aid this time
it's Elastigirl going out being a
superhero
she probably finds out what's really
going on then the whole family gets in
on the action with the addition of Jack
Jack who they're still using mostly for
comedy he is pretty much every Power
that you could imagine but I think the
whole idea is is that they're trying to
say that mr. incredible it needs to be
an awesome dad because his kids have
crazy awesome superpowers so the more
well-adjusted they are the better they
work together
the quicker they're able to put the beat
down on all the villains but that was
kind of a subplot in the first film
where the kids needed to believe in
themselves in order to fully activate
their powers
[Music]
in related superhero news because Black
Panther is out pretty much everywhere
around the world I'll start doing my
post credit scene videos tonight my
spoilery review will post tomorrow and
then obviously a whole bunch of Avengers
infinity war we'll talk about how the
end of Black Panther in the stuff that
they do in that movie will affect the
larger Marvel Universe so just post all
your questions that you want me to
include in those videos in the comments
below but while you wait for everything
click here to learn about Thor's new
weapon during infinity war and click
here to learn all about spider-man's new
armor thank you so much for watching
everybody stay incredible I will see you
guys tonight